[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun very
excited to be talking about art and
emotional expression we have Athena Kim
joining us on the show hello hello
thanks for coming on Athena thank you so
much for having me here really excited
for this you reminded me that it's been
a long time since we've actually known
each other when I first came at the bay
area about seven years ago that's true
yeah that's a long time for a bay area
yeah friend yeah cuz so many people are
just meeting so recently and so it's
cool that we've known each other a while
you've grown a lot as a human I have too
for those that don't know Athena's
background Dena Kim is a painter living
in the Bay Area whose abstract
expressionism embodies complex personal
feelings and body sensations each of her
works is a profound personal journey
into the depths of the subconscious and
past personal experiences as a result
they culminate in unique compositions of
richly colored abstract images which
fill large canvases with gestures lines
shapes and colors that evoke feelings of
transcendence and tranquility so
beautiful and you find the links in the
bio below Athena Kim art calm as well as
her instagram and facebook athena let's
start things off by understanding who
you are in your journey so you're born
in Seoul in South Korea and who were you
growing up how did you get interested in
art
I don't exactly remember how I think
your Sinatra but what I do remember as a
kid I was always a drawing and it was
always like a visually very interested
and that responsive and drawing painting
wasn't one of my favorite things to do
the hours could pass by easily yeah
what were you drawing painting when you
were young mostly the sceneries
landscapes and also sky stars and what
was it like growing up in South Korea
haha
I personally it was a very dark heavy I
I was a gifted child so at a very early
age I started getting a lot of
expectations from parents and school
teachers and there was a huge emphasis
on doing well in the school exams and
getting into a top college that was the
only way that you could like make it
from working class to I don't know like
a middle class or with other
opportunities and possibilities
and so those expectations were were
heavy yeah I'm the eldest of three and
both of my parents came from a very
humble family so Lee related had nothing
and I had to build something and they
believed in the power of education so
they wished me till I have a different
life which is a better life
so they made a huge sacrifice putting us
into private education with a huge loans
and they were living extremely frugally
and yeah and then they were very worried
about what other people think about how
they did with their life which is also
very common culture in Korea I think
especially eldest and also gifted child
there is a extra expectations on me that
I should do weld and then they wanted to
live there like dream that got through
me
almost yeah
and then do you continue also having the
your emotional expression through art
throughout your like teenage years and
through your 20s unfortunately no I
think I had that creative outlet when I
was in a private elementary school with
the extracurricular events the classes
but not was I got into junior high
school it was all about getting perfect
grades and school tests and no other
extracurricular activities so my father
coming off of the private piano lessons
I was a getting when I was in elementary
school which I was like a most
passionate about so Wow yeah we have a
lot to change about our world to make it
easier for kids to pursue what they
actually find most interesting and not
be just squelched by the by the economic
and political and parental machinery
saying you have to do this yeah I
totally with you on that but in Korea is
like a people mindset mentality the kids
who are not smart or not academically
accomplished but coming from a lot of
money they get art lessons and go to our
schools
so it's not really like a cool thing to
do especially our family didn't have a
lot of funds so I remember my mother
tell me like I wish and I could support
you if you wanted to go to art school
instead but unfortunately we can but
fortunately you are very smart
you're doing so well in school so why
didn't you go to college and then make
an art as a hobby it'd be cool to be a
doctor or professor and in a painting on
the side they'll be better for you
that's what my mother told me but if I
had a choice
to do whatever what what I wanted to do
then I would totally go for a heart
doing other school work was to partially
make my parents proud and happy up
endure sacrifices and also I understood
like an important of getting education
it was just socially like a strong
emphasis like since I was a very little
so yeah and then did how did you end up
then transitioning from South Korea to
the Bay Area yeah I think it's around in
my mid-30s I started traveling to San
Francisco I think I was a working as a
freelance Korean English translator
interpreter so I had a flexibility with
some savings and then that's when I got
into like a personal healing journey I
sing psychologist and doing meditation
and making a lot of self reflections
which I didn't think that I had a luxury
to do for a butte Akkad's of my life
and then coming to San Francisco was
kind of taking a break from a very
somewhat stressful and overwhelmingly
like happy person at work I was doing in
Korea okay so then there was a process
of wanting to heal and having a
psychiatry as well as meditations these
types of processes for you in terms of
healing and would you say that then art
was then another modality for you for
healing another way to heal I didn't
have a full understanding of the healing
power of art it was just I had a really
difficult time to acknowledge and
navigate my feelings and emotions during
30 mm with a psychologist so every time
I go to see her at her office she asked
me a question how are you feeling then
I'll just get stuck and not knowing how
to answer the question not knowing what
my feelings are yeah and then one day
she knew that were frustrating I was
frustrated I was and then handed me a
sketchbook with the crayons and asked me
to just a draw Wow and I did it was it
was kind like a Red John drawing and
they started painting with the colors
and then there's a relief and kind of
Joyce it's like opening and in my body
that seems that I relieve the
frustration or the discomfort that was
experiencing so after after that I
started drawing on my own
Wow that's a interesting healing
practice that even like a psychologist
if they can identify that someone if
they can use a sketchpad with some
crayons to express how they're feeling
that can be a really good way to get
people to actually express themselves
mm-hmm yeah and so then did you when you
were when you were expressing yourself
then that was kind of the moment for you
of like maybe I should do this more no
it didn't occur to me that way I was
doing more and more because there was a
benefit that was eginning okay there's a
kind of sense of relief like even
liberation and it interests me what what
comes on the canvas because it's a blank
canvas and sketchbook and I didn't have
any intention or purpose of what I was
going to draw or paint yeah so I just
stay with it and then just let my
fingers or wherever it leads I'm just
gonna go with it
and something very interesting like keep
coming that made me curious and also
help me navigate the feelings that I
could have figured out for myself and it
gives me a sort of like a data something
like tangible to look at yes
and then ponder yeah around
you said a relief and liberation yeah
and then it gives you something tangible
to look at and yeah and ponder afterward
and then you started that practice more
and more when you were in the bay oh
when I was in the bay while I was just
traveling back and forth
yeah then when yeah when did you pick up
starting to do this more and more I
think that was around least summer 2016
mm-hmm that was after I had really huge
panic attacks with anxiety and triggers
of a past trauma when I was in a
relationship and there's there's a lot
of like abuse that I suffer from and
I don't know how it happened like one
day I picked up the paints and started
painting on canvas
and and I haven't stopped since three
years of continuing to paint on canvas
yeah
yeah the relief and liberation something
to look at and ponder yeah and and even
then people really love this work your
art they're purchasing it for their
offices for their homes for their
because they they really enjoy the work
and so there's kind of like both you get
the benefit of the relief and liberation
other people get to see something
beautiful right in their homes offices
yeah yeah I didn't in pain to sell it
was that meant for sale and then one day
a friend I came visit with her friends
and then her friend wanted to buy a
painting yeah and which is a big
surprise at the time I was not really a
for selling it because I felt like the
painting is a piece of me and then it's
like letting the part of me let go but
at the time I and that figure I just
don't need to let go mm-hmm
but later there's the gratitude and the
joy and sense of a fulfillment it came
to me that it's a better off to go you
know away from me and then be
appreciated yes yes yeah
appreciated by more people yeah yeah and
so then this expression of emotions
through art let's let's start also
showing some of the first collections
the interoception collection so this art
here is how does this art how is this
art made how does this how does this
work how do you do this oh how did I
create it and what is interoception what
is this collection how did you create it
it's all this stuff yeah well when I
paint I don't even know like what's
gonna come out I set on a blank canvas
and meditate first and they get myself
rented and just to keep an open mind
with curiosity and then just to let my
subconsciousness and then my my hand
just leave me I was going through a lot
when I created the beginning of an
interception series usually I titled the
series after the paintings are completed
I was staying at a friend's couch for
sever a month in San Francisco and
I think I stretched the canvas with the
help from an artist friend so it was a
free supplies were offered and I I found
is a very inexpensive that paints in the
art supply store and I was seeing a
therapist once a week and just started
going to a meditation group my life was
unlike limbo with total uncertainty not
knowing where to go next and I don't
even know like if I could like I
survived
yeah was it was it was a lot but at
least it's something that I could do
there there's so many things that are
out of my control
yes but I think I was trying to like
focus and things that I can do within my
control for me having a canvas just you
know set took a space that gave me a
sense of security the safety that I
could create within within the space as
I wanted but not having tried to like
execute some things try to make
something taking off the pressure of me
and then that whatever that comes and
just go let them come out and express it
to have a space like a canvas to be able
to design exactly what you want versus
the outside world it's so out of control
right even that I didn't have my own
like a physical space I was a living off
my suitcase on someone's a couch and I
move around quite a lot and not knowing
where to go next and how long I could
stay but at least when it comes to the
painting I have this in the canvas and
and just do with it yeah and that was
really difficult to even Explorer and
navigate understand what was going
through and how does
from everything that you're feeling to
the way that you're using materials you
said you kind of meditate and then you
let your even subconscious just take you
interesting so what yeah so what would
that look like so is this oil no mixed
up mediums I had some like charcoals and
pencils and oil pastels and acrylic
paint okay acrylic oil pastels charcoal
and crayons and pencils wow that's a lot
of stuff yeah yeah okay so then you get
a little bit of all of those involved
and yeah whatever whatever it feels
right to me and the moment I go with it
my works are not premeditated yeah yeah
that's uh and they have like a layer of
texture on them because like some of the
they're like raised up a little bit
right what do you call that when there's
that layer of like that added layer of
texture
I call it layers layers so when I feel
something or try to like navigate
explore what's going on inside my body
there are a lot of physical sensations
that come and go
I find body skinny from mindfulness
meditation yes
very helpful it helps me better present
and sensitive and mindful of the
sensation I'm going through and then
also help me
naming emotions that rise with the
physical sensations which I was not able
to do used to feel like it is too
overwhelming like too like powerful
something is like hijacking me it's just
like there's so much like energy that I
am completely taken by which made me
feel helpless
but when I do the painting works it
helps me feel grounded because I it's
like invite all of them and embrace them
and let them all come out come out on
canvas there there are so many of it and
I don't I don't really know what they
are but there's so much of it but to me
comes as a colors textures and movements
when I navigate physical sensations
emotions and feelings and sometimes the
memories from the past and also like
being present and my understanding is a
body carries a lot of memories body
holds of the score yeah and then I I
want to like relieved relieved all just
stuff like a taken my space I want like
the create some open space so I could I
could be better present
whoa so so different feelings when you
do the meditation body scan different
feelings will will trigger different
movements and different colors and
different textures and do you have a can
you give us an example of like a feeling
and a color that you would use with that
feeling can they associate the colors
with like emotions yeah yeah
well I would say like a blue is like
commie coming and grounded impact on me
but at times it could be very deep and
if it gets for example if I work on like
a blue painting series for like hundreds
of hours for a long period of time then
I get I get like really like taken down
as if I'm like sinking like under like a
deep ocean then when I when I go start
working on like a yellow like an orange
and the green the more vibrant colors
that I find the more uplifting that
brings me like more life and like a
vibrancy
honestly I don't really think about it
like logically okay it's a red is like a
passion or it's like word tragic so I'm
going to use a red but I'm there but are
there patterns that you see though like
in in the choices that you make like a
certain feeling triggers a certain
texture or us or a body stroke so when
they when that work on the paintings I
don't really think like everything like
happens so so like quickly then I'm
really like immerse in painting so I
don't really like think or analyze yes
correct because that takes you out of
flow yeah right so I'm like in the flow
yeah yes yeah yeah and then what's the
difference between the the interception
collection and like the next collection
which is this blue space nebula
collection what's the differences
between the collections well blue space
nebula collection was born because of
our Commission it was a first our
Commission that I received from
a couple whom I met at mindfulness based
stress reduction workshop so they loved
all my works once they saw my online
gallery images and they both agreed that
blue is their favorite color and then
wanted me to create something that's
tranquil and serene and they actually
totally left it up to me and I I had no
idea other than I'm going to use a blue
as like a primary color which is my most
favorite not noise very little and I
love the ocean blue sky your and a deep
blue of the universe yes and continue on
the story oh so like not knowing like
what to create so just the way I you
know painted it before I just started
started with it and then as the painting
like constantly to proceed so Lisa she's
in one of the collectors who
commissioned a piece came by and told me
that she is seeing a nebula on the
painting and I never heard that word
before
so she Google searches and then show the
image of nebula then I could see like
similarities so but I was not painting
to create nebula yeah yeah yeah but it
continues to evolve and they're like
bunch of neighbors like stopping by I
was a painting in their garage and then
that's what most people were seeing
universe or consolation
nebula's yeah so that's interesting so
you weren't thinking cosmology but
people came and saw nebulas and
constellations in the universe right
that's great but it all like came from
within myself it's like sitting like a
total like a self phase you know is that
whatever it comes as a welcome and just
stop believe in yourself and just uh
just go with it with intuition maybe
there was something as large as nebulas
and constellations channeling through
you actually like a few female
collectors and mention it to me and I I
always feel very surreal when I see my
works it's like I cannot believe that I
am doing this like did I do this really
I did it and I don't know like how but
it keeps it coming at me I love the
expression
there's someone saying you are the
universe we are we're the universe like
in a park like a huge like universe yes
observing and experiencing we are the
universe observing experiencing itself
yeah mm-hmm yeah and I believe if I
really surrender myself and like to all
the possibilities and infinity coming
from the mother of nature and the
universe and it will just work through
me and then things are going to be just
I love that
okay yeah so and then I I got very
inspired by the first piece I was
creating and so both collectors that
they couldn't be happier and then I
wanted to take advantage of having the
space to create a large work so I told
them that I like to create one more and
then let them decide which piece said
they wanted to pick and because I didn't
have a studio at the time I was I was
painting on the living room floor next
to couch and the dining table these were
like six foot pieces oh this is five by
seven feet five or seven feet right how
do you fit that on a living room floor
oh so I couldn't do it there so that's
why I painted in my collectors garage
your color if you're right
yeah yeah okay okay yeah so there was
there were there was oh there were these
people that would help give you the
right space that you needed in order to
have the creative expression come
through you because you needed the space
you needed the we need the help
sometimes from people that yeah they
believe in us of course they had higher
believe in my talent and me as a person
more than I did for myself at the time
it was November 2017
and it was I cannot believe that you
guys have like such a like hi
believe in me because it was a five
figure Commission work which is
excellent which is a nice amount of
money yeah I don't think it's like
easier for even like people with money
what is that
yeah so they had they believed in me and
then they opened their house to me for
me to work and that's how this series
were able to yeah yeah Lauren that's
beautiful
and like the amount of 5 feet by 7 feet
would you say um would you say a
majority of the things that you're
painting are that size I created 2 5 by
7 feet canvas paintings and 10 506 big
cats hang 5 by 6 feet right Wow
no 5 I yeah 10 yeah wow that's huge yeah
whoa
I gained a huge self-confidence after I
completed a successful first hour
Commission on 5i 17 feet canvas and I
created the second piece and then which
was sold last year by worldly renown
venture capitalists in Silicon Valley
which is also amazing and so with the
money that I received from the first
hour Commission I set my intention for
the first time and decide to invest into
buying our supplies including ten five
by six we canvass
and ordered 25 boxes of paint Wow and
had no clue
where where to paint and what you do
with those paints of boxes of paint
right and the miraculously I was able to
like a finest space to move into
temporarily yeah and live and work yes
that was in Berkeley yes right see this
is this is you you took a big risk you
double down on what you love and more
doors kept opening up yes they're
probably not not the most practical
decision I think the enormous the
pressure of not having a lot of things
out of my control
uncertainty I feel like I want to do
something totally opposite mmm-hmm
because I fear that otherwise it's gonna
it's gonna take over me yes
I don't know I don't like feeling
defeated yeah yeah so it was a very bold
decision of course there's a lot of fear
what if I can sell them what I'm gonna
do with this thing
gigantic painting I can't keep them and
I don't have my own space and my life is
still in limbo and but I did and then it
paid off yeah yeah yeah this is a great
story of believing in oneself and taking
the next steps towards what you find
most meaningful in your life and
pursuing that even though there can be
some fear or some anxiety about what
could happen it's better to go through
to what you love than to turn around and
say I don't I don't think I can do
mm-hmm it's a reoccurring theme of the
people we sit down with now I loved this
the vulnerability collection when did
you start the vulnerability collection
that was in September last year 2018 I
was in descent early relationship I was
a totally in love with this man but he
was not and to me and I was I was a
fearful of getting my heart broken but I
couldn't like stop loving him and like
it's like my heart was like a rushing
out and I had just like a fear of
rejection that comes as a few small
episode a panic attacks and anxiety
which made my body feel very you know
disorienting so I wanted to like out
work through them somehow and I chose
like painting as my creative outlet and
kind like a process zone so the first I
vulnerability piece actually it was
supposed to be the first layer of blue
space a painting aha and I just you know
left it because it takes time for the
paints that dry and
I I post each painting that I create
unto my social media accounts and there
is an immediate response positive
feedbacks from the viewers on Instagram
and their Facebook so I figure okay I'm
just gonna leave it as it is and see
like what happens and then I received a
facebook messenger with a facebook
friend request from Elliott in London
who was interested in buying this piece
with blue space nebula number five Wow
which I thought that was a kind of joke
because there's a person I'd never met
we don't have any mutual contacts
Wow around the world what we can see now
is the interconnected world can do
things like someone can follow your
account see this post have no mutual
friends with you but is looking for
artists that are kind of you know unique
he wasn't even looking he's never bought
paintings ever before and just this one
just got him and he got interested in
walking actually it was my facebook
profile photo he's standing next to a
blue space number one that picture got
his attention okay and then he started
clicking my account and saw this image
that was the latest work that I posted
at the time ok and then so then you sent
this one to Elliott then he actually
came visit me and bravely he showed up
Wow and met me and sell my paintings and
purchased two large paintings Wow
and the Commission a small piece as a
tribute to his father who passed away as
a Holocaust survivor from Poland
Athena this is so cool this has all
happened in the last year for you yes
right now at least I got something out
of this you know relationship that
didn't work out I was devastated oh my
god this is happening again
why is it happening whoa look there why
it happened potentially yeah but at
least I got something really positive
which made like a huge positive impact
and momentum for my artists career maybe
this is exactly what was meant to happen
from the relationship that didn't work
out its potential possible you are a
channel that's veena see when our
relationship our failed doomed
relationship with bring to fruition in
the art world
I joke I didn't touch II just was better
off being quiet but you know pain you
know can create wonderful art yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's eventually at some
point I can see more young people around
the world being able to express
themselves through art in more mediums
right now we have the benefit of
something like Instagram like you were
saying or Facebook also YouTube through
video distribution right all these types
of mediums that help us artistically
distribute content I think it's only
there's more and more billions of more
people that are going to be coming onto
the platforms it's gonna be crazy to see
what cool art yeah comes up I think that
digital social media plan
has given me this opportunity to
showcase and selling work Nelly
locally and internationally yeah I don't
have a you know our gallery
representation I'm still looking for the
right fit so I've been doing everything
from scratch from creating artworks
logistics and sales and promotion and
marketing and social media content
management yeah it's hard it's a lot of
work you're wearing all the hats and so
you're looking to potentially put some
of the works into galleries yes yes okay
I think that would help me just focusing
on creating artwork not having to worry
about all this like business business
stuff yeah we're sort get an agent to
help you with that side the business
development side yeah so Athena is
looking for galleries for potentially
someone to help with business yes
dealers dealers right okay cool
okay cool and then the contact is right
on the website right for the contact
form so for those I want again that's
Athena Kmart comm if those are
interested please reach out to Athena we
would love to see more of this and so
you can focus on what yet keep this
channel going so okay and then the more
on the vulnerability collection it seems
as though here your the the the feeling
in being expressed through the body
motion is like pretty evident it's
pretty visible yes yes so the canvas is
that larger than my body under five
three feet and this is a five a six bead
I was just uh you know throwing the
paint's walking around and sometimes
like a runny
I love this like a physical like a
movements allow me to you know move and
make this you know Amy collie talking
about in the body language I how it
impacts our psychology yes I think I
tend to feel very small and like this
and then and then that impacts my psyche
psyche and also commotion makes me even
more you know close up and you know that
give me depressed or not feel so safe
but when I started getting a moving my
body there's you know can I flow like a
space and more like in the power you
know opening I think that's that's what
attracts me to work on a large canvas
because that kind of boosts all this
non-physical like emotions which gives
me the larger sensation of liberation or
relief yeah
if the this similarly with with just
movement in general for those that are
constantly behind computers all day to
just get up move stretch the body do
some yoga go outside get some sunlight
without the phones that that can
rejuvenate and inspire and give us so
much energy and so you're right that
like if you're on a big canvas it's
bigger than your body and you're using
these large movement strokes yeah you're
inevitably going to feel more alive yes
yeah yes yeah
and so the vulnerability collection
continues Wow
that smote work as sold oh this one got
sold yeah wow congratz just met Tom Tom
bought it oh that's so cool it's so nice
yeah damn so we started piece in person
he said yes right away no but it's so
cool Wow
so so and this is now becoming a
reoccurring thing like people even
working at the major tech companies in
the Bay Area are like interested in
purchasing supporting the art and yeah
that's beautiful yeah we need more I'm
always on the lookout for our collectors
exhibitors and also you know corporate
collaborations yeah yes yeah okay
ah yeah I think I saw one of the images
on on you have so much everyone everyone
should follow
Athena Kim art on Instagram because
there's just so much good stuff on here
and they think I saw one of the one of
the images like these are some of the
kind of like some of the large is this
is this in the office space oh that's
not currently in my studio gallery this
one's in the studio I saw some of the
ones that looked like I love because I
love the brick background it kind of
looks like the in the office space
because that's another one of the things
is that it's coming in - yeah this is
the one at the venture capital oh cool
fabrications design studio space in Palo
Alto nice it's call playground global
there's a second large piece Congrats so
cool thank you see this is getting your
your see you're moving you're moving
fast it's beautiful to see it because it
takes a long time you know it's not
overnight on the pursuit of art in the
pursuit of of what brings someone
meaning in life sometimes we are so in
the instant gratification world that we
forget that it takes it took
Michelangelo almost four years to make
the Statue of David right yeah I just
said you know came after it was Andy
Warhol's exhibitions he says so sucks a
print so it's easy the work is super
easy and then much quicker and then he
could produce so much in the next short
period of time I was like my work takes
so much time and it's uh you know my
hand and the huge physical labor but
there is a there's a beauty in it I
think that's what keeps keeps me like
gravitated it's it's so difficult you
know working on canvas with a pain ten
hours a day and and I pass out oh yeah
when I'm like in the flow yeah ten
twelve hours go you know fast
and then it's not even done a single one
Oh cuz I have a many layers and it's
layered so you you put the layer on one
and then you're going to the other one
and can what you're making a second or
third layer on the one that is already
dried from yesterday right oh my gosh
and it is like it difficult to like put
the brushes and paint a palette knife
down and then go for a walk and take a
break for coffee because it has to be
the timing is so important so right
mixture as a color and then create a
certain like textures that that I want
and then it has to be the right having a
happy that way if I miss it and it will
take tremendous amount of time and like
a paints to like try to recreate it so
so one of the things is that then it's
as though you have like this is
potentially like a good example let's
look at this one so there's something
like it's almost as though that you the
when you when you add a color and you
wait just a couple seconds and then you
add another color it mixes differently
then if you waited an hour like if you
went on a walk and then came back it
would make a different appearance right
yeah yeah so you didn't you get to pick
which ones you want to do immediately
which ones you want to wait a couple
minutes or maybe an hour or maybe even
overnight to let it completely dry yeah
yeah yeah so it's a totally intuitive
spontaneous at time is not accident yeah
does it make sense yeah
I'm not planning it's not premeditated
but I am looking for kind of like
serendipity while like being in present
in the flow
yeah yep serendipity and inflow yep yeah
wow there's so much complexity that goes
into this and I'm happy that we are even
starting to you know break down the
complexity and also showcase more
artists that are doing really well and
now we believe in and that we love
supporting and thank you not that you're
so welcome you're so welcoming and you
have such a unique edge to you too
because like you said that there's
there's something beautiful about you
said post-traumatic growth mm-hmm I love
that because we all have some sort of
trauma varying levels of traumas and
stresses throughout our lives as well as
our ancestors lives right and so how can
we grow from that that's such an
important thing you are the embodiment
of that I am I am working on it in
progress
I think it
I I came to realize that I was suffering
from PTSD for a few decades of my life
but with this fear that I didn't want
anybody to know what was going on then
what happened to me
I think it has a lot to do with the
shame I think it's a very common
psychological like a challenge that a
survivor of a trauma the experience even
though it's not at our fault it happened
to us
but we we are so shut down and too
afraid to acknowledge and you know have
our voice to you know tell others
because we're so worried of being
labeled or a judge or a criticize not
having a sense of a safety which is the
biggest struggle for me yeah
in Suzuka half-space that makes us feel
safe to be vulnerable and to express
ourselves at our deepest emotions is so
critical and to help provide that for
other people by just being present with
them and the way that they feel and just
wanting to be there in a loving caring
compassionate way and also to be able to
do things like express oneself through
art and mediums like art Athena did we
do you think we covered do you think we
covered everything well do you think is
there something else specific that you
think we should mention about your art
and about your journey
how do you feel feel good
thinking they're thinking pretty good
I'm thinking we did a good job
so some and also this is also important
to mention that some of the some of the
the canvas is although you use some five
by six and some survived by seven-foot
canvases you also you even gifted us a
little um what was that like a twelve
inch by 12 inch that was a sixteen by
twenty sixteen by twenty yes so these
are sixteen by twenty or a little bit
more even maybe like right 18 by 22 seem
brighter yeah okay well I still make
smaller work small medium large and you
know extra large canvases yeah cool and
so you're doing yeah both scales right
now big stuff and smaller stuff you're
doing both right especially in San
Francisco and like not everybody has you
know like huge white wall space although
we definitely at some point will need to
get one of the one of the beautiful ones
in here or even just lease it from you
for a period of time to hang and and
inspire other people that that come in
and we'll mention that of course it's
Athena Cuba's art so thank you I know
like there's there's like a ton of money
in Silicon Valley in Santa Bay area yeah
like just even this year there's like
new thousands you know like a
millionaires
there's new millionaires all the time
yeah oh that's so pass on some of that
wealth too yeah I need all this like
successful tech entrepreneurs investors
to invest and support the artists that's
right so art is so essential yes you are
him in especially all this you know the
most cutting-edge tech
in the Bay Area especially I feel like
they they have this accountability to
support artists yes yes you look back at
Lorenzo de Medici patronage da Vinci and
Michelangelo right you this is this is a
long time that this has been happening
we need more of these new tech
millionaires to step up and say I'm
gonna give a thena Kim because I love
her art I'm gonna give her a thousand
bucks a month they're gonna give
simulation a thousand bucks a month
because they love what we do they're
gonna give charity Evert a thousand
bucks a month because she'd they love
what she does yeah just like in a
venture capitalist and angel investor
invest they're like tens and nine
hundred thousand dollars into tech
startups because they believe in their
potentials and they want to support so
why not for artists why can they invest
into artists with the talents and the
vision and support them yes yes Amen
we're gonna we're move we're making the
move there that's where everything's
going Athena or me we're making the move
in that direction where one one person
at a time one supporting artists moving
people in that direction
Athena let's ask you a couple quick
questions that we like asking our guests
on the way out of the show okay okay
okay so what do you where do you think
we come from before birth do we come
from
somewhere into these bodies personally
I cannot explain it there's no you know
data but it's just purely based on my
intuition just gut feeling we all come
from somewhere but not necessarily
somewhere like completely new I don't
like a nothing or it could be I can say
like I'm a firm believer of
reincarnation but maybe there was like a
huge kind of like a circle I don't know
mm-hmm unless that we like completely
release and they relieve all this our
Karma yeah then there is like a nothing
left doesn't need to be like a brought
back mm-hmm until it gets to a point
maybe the speaking of it kind of sounds
like a reincarnation even though I don't
necessarily believe it and I don't know
it well
because often I get this kind of
sensation that like things that I see
and when I'm experiencing it's it's it
feels kind of familiarity yeah oh yeah
it's like a memory from the far past I
don't even know when it was and what it
was for yeah yeah the ultimate
remembering why are we here what are we
doing what is our role
what's our puzzle piece in the big game
of civilization
the big remembering Athena do you think
we are in a simulation yes yes we are
tell me more why it's a it's like a
wonderful choice for where your series
tell me why that's so difficult I'm
usually like I just know but when I have
to explain and analyze it mm-hmm
I don't really have like a firm like
exclamation to it it's a coffin for me
like I just know mm-hmm
and then what do you thinks the most
beautiful thing in the world most
beautiful thing in the world
compassion
and is unconditional based on the
unconditional love CFN take pure that
caring for another living being yeah
that's so beautifully said Athena yeah
thank you thank you thank you for
joining us on the show we really
appreciate it half of you as a guest
thank you for having me today
Ellen Ryan thank you so much thank
Supino you're a huge inspiration to us
we hope that everyone that watched we
would love for you to also check out the
links in the bio below to athena Kim our
comm also the Instagram and Facebook
pages Athena can mark check those out
everyone go and support Athena
share more conversations with our
friends our families our co-workers
people online on social media about art
and emotional expression in general get
creating as an artist get making go do
that everyone we love you thank you for
tuning in
leave us your thoughts in the comments
below also support the entrepreneur is
the organization the artists around the
world that you believe in simulation our
links are below support us on PayPal on
patreon also on cryptocurrencies if you
want do cool things like design merch
like what's the most beautiful thing in
the world you can do that the links
below you can get paid and you can also
spread thought-provoking questions
around the world shout out to Ronda
Vargas for producing and directing thank
you very much Ron and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world thanks for tuning in and
we will see you soon peace
[Music]
you
[Music]